الان نعرض هذه الصور لكاميرا مراقبه
كاميرا مراقبه تظهر تسلل قوه خاصه
اسرائيليه داخل مستشفى ابن سينا في مدينه
جنين لاغتيال ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين اذا
صور كاميرا مراقبه تظهر تسلل قوه خاصه
اسرائيليه داخل مستشفى ابن سينا في مدينه
جنين لاغتيال ثلاثه شبان فلس ينيين وكنا
قد نقلنا في بدايه هذه النشره خبر اغتيال
ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين داخل هذا المستشفى
بعد ان دخلت قوات اسرائيليه متنكره بزي
مدني
لتغتسل كاتم للصوت ثلاثه شبان احدهم مصاب
كان يتلقى العلاج في هذا المستشفى وقتلته
مع شابين اخرين كانا يرافقان و تعتبر طبعا
هذه السابقه في الضفه الغربيه لجوء قواه
الاحتلال لهذا الاسلوب لاغتيال مقاومين
فلسطينيين اذا مازلنا معكم مشاهدينا في
متابعه هذه الصور التي وردتنا وهي لصور
كاميرا مراقبه
في المستشفى مستشفى ابن سينا في جنين وهي
اول صور تظهر تسلل قوه خاصه اسرائيليه
داخل مستشفى ابن سينا في مدينه جنين
لاغتيال ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين كما
ذكرنا في سابقه من نوعها في الضفه الغربيه